okay so the latest episode of rick and
morty is now out and the entry title
ethic twin stink has a lot going on with
it it's obviously named after the film
basic instinct with michael douglas and
sharon stone and just like that film
we've been slowing it down zooming in
and also getting as close as we can to
make sure we unearth all the
easter eggs hidden details and things
you missed to turn the brightness up to
turn the brightness
as you can guess the episode centers
around spacebath spending some time with
the family this is also a thanksgiving
special and we begin with a call back to
the last thanksgiving episode from the
fifth season episode six of that run was
titled thanksploitation spectacular and
had both rick and morty transforming
into turkeys this was so that they could
get pardoned by the president and this
is a tradition that's believed to have
been started all the way back in the
1870s since then presidents have
pardoned turkeys almost every single
year and rick ends up flying into the
window disguise this one he says pardon
the interruption we are once again in
the federal clear he also asks how
morty's got such an advanced game
console and first refers to it as the
public key in game pod you also get this
line about portals go let's get out of
it i heard you smack the glass dad if
you bail i'll just stop yeah i'd say
don't hop through a portal but oh wait
you can't now season five ended with
evil morty rerouting all the portal guns
so that they led to instant death for
the characters you might have noticed
that they haven't used them at all in
these first three episodes and that's
why they were marooned in space now we
do know that there's a golden one out
there that doesn't kill the user and it
might end up being the thing that's
brought across now rick stands there
naked the entire time but we see in the
next scene that he could have put
clothes on completely effortlessly
showing the man just wanted to flex
these sort of popping balloon over him
but it reminded me a lot of the marvel
nano machine suit upset have now become
commonplace i love this slide as well
life is a subscription and thanksgiving
is your family's yearly charge never
celebrate thanksgiving myself because
i'm from england and i'm thankful every
single year that i don't have to the
dislike button is right there and i'll
understand if you hit it see you chump
now jerry ends up giving a big speech
and in the end he reveals that he'd end
his own life if he ever lost beth
weirdly we've actually seen what happens
to him if he has a life without her and
he sort of becomes his own version of
rick completely isolated and better
anyway from here we go to the title
sequence and if you enjoy the breakdown
then please hit the thumbs up button and
make sure you subscribe for videos like
this every day by the way huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into the
rest of the episode
[Music]
now from here we could to the best
chatting away in the kitchen and this
episode is basically about learning to
love yourself
which is a nice message i guess lots of
trying to bone your clone and we see the
pair flitting away with space beth
planning a translation chip in the back
of home bet's neck this is something
that was first featured in marvel comics
and at one point king the conqueror even
gave his younger self there so that he
could continue the path to turn into his
older vision these were both kang
similar how beth are both beths but that
involved the bootstrap paradox whereas
these are just duplicates the wine that
space beth has clearly makes people
squanchy and this is why we see rick
locking it up behind a mind-bending
window cabinet at the end of the episode
i think that this is using a pocket
dimension in order to be hidden away
rather than it's just being a fake
window we saw something similar in
peacemaker when we watched where the
peacemaker and his father hid away their
costumes i'm guessing that this means
rick actually wanted something like this
to happen which he later talks about
with the whale don't worry about what's
crazy you know as the kids say you do
you he might have even been through this
himself and he keeps an ice cream tub
just in case he needs to pretend he's
been out for some space beth brings up
his ship is bigger on the inside which
is of course a nod of the tardis from
doctor who and it might also work in a
similar method to how the window does
courteuric morty and summer playing a
game based on asteroids the popular 1978
cabinet game that ended up being
introduced to homes on the atari the
three decided to crank the realism up
with the higher settings being closer to
what space is actually like it's
completely devoid of asteroids and the
player dies before ever coming across
one just before they do this we see that
there's a donut shape in the top right
hand corner of the game and this is
actually what many believe that the
universe looks like scientists were able
to examine radiation from the first
stages of its creation and they
discovered that the universe is
constantly expanding however in order to
do this they theorized that it would
also have to loop in on itself rather
than being flat or like a box now
episode one of this season had i not to
tony leaving a message to pepper in
avengers endgame and we sort of get
something similar here with morty's ship
being adrift he leaves a message for his
hypothetical son but we of course know
that the character actually had one with
summer in season 5 episode 4. titled
rick dependence spray it was another one
i incest you watch and it's brought up
by space beth at the end outside beth
and space beth almost kiss and this
brings a new meaning to the word
masturbation anyway back in the game we
see a street fighter parody called
getting to a street fight this centers
around fighters trying to meet up and we
see that the two characters are based on
ryu and blanca from that game the modes
include a battle royale meth mode pants
free urban and slapper zoney which is
like newcastle's big market on a
saturday night hey
they also drink lots of green energy
drinks based on mountain dew that we can
see are called battery fuel down said
big market i learned that a vodka and
mountain dew is called rocket fuel and
the company also has lots of tie-ins
with game releases one of the drinks is
called game fuel but hey i prefer a
night on the town with some slappers and
me rock if you like come on
later on they also play a parody of
final fantasy vii but in this cloud is
too weak to pick up his buster sword the
two bats go on a date together above the
planet earth and this reminded me a lot
of the dayton passengers they also talk
about a space station which that film
took place on and it's a really
underrated movie that looks great in 4k
so if you're interested in that yeah go
pick it up thanks thanks for the money
as well chris i also think that we see a
decoy body as well which was featured in
the second episode of season two the
pair get it on with both summer and
morty being traumatized by what they've
witnessed jerry still doesn't notice
because he's stupid there's a bit in
which they go over how summer normally
picks up on things first before morty
does could to rick ripping apart a space
well and these creatures are featured in
a lot of tv shows books and also movies
the idea of them first popped up in the
1970s with the oceans being likened to
the vastness of space the eerie and
otherworldly whale song was also a
purpose for their appearance and i also
got a lot of flashes of jaws here in
that movie they of course could open a
shark early on but it turns out that
rick actually wants to help the whale
out on the roof the beth's make snow
angels when rolling around kissing and
the arms on these are together
symbolizing the two people actually
being the same they blow shapes with
their vape pens and this reminded me a
lot of gandalf and bilbo doing in the
fellowship of the ring after completing
his jigsaw and realizing it's a horse
joey plays hide the affair a
role-playing game about two women having
an affair together in this star trek s
color deck we see that the bets have
aged up and spent their lives together
which rick refers to as a san junipero
this is a title of a black mirror
episode in which two women fell in love
together in a simulation that i won't
spoil the ending of in case you haven't
seen it hey i might be the spoiler man
but i'm not like that madison from the
mcu ruining the sopranos i don't care if
it's been 15 years i might have
eventually got around to watching it now
jerry remembers the time that he was
warned about her in high school and
literally retreats into his shell which
we learned he had installed by rick this
is based on a pill bug's ability to roll
up and rick explains it's the only way
he can take control rick got matching
eagle tattoos instead and this allows
jerry to avoid talking about wonder
woman 1984 which i'm ashamed to admit
that i gave an 8 out of 10 too it look
it was different times it was the
pandemic i don't want to talk about
it now we could of the family playing a
text based game that used to be popular
before graphics really took center stage
the text layout is similar to the matrix
and it's about the group waking up in a
forest that they're unable to escape
from eventually the vampires take over
and i i have no idea what's going on i
know rick explained it but still no idea
the home bet slowly starts to gravitate
towards cherry due to his vulnerability
which space beth of course doesn't have
the pair had their lives together in
what home beth refers to as a video game
again calling back to this simulation
they decide to erase their memories and
they end up sitting in chairs that
pulled directly from total recall rick
also mentioned several movies including
eternal sunshine of a spotless mind
which was about jim carrey's character
erasing the memories of his ex so that
he could get over her rick also talks
about multiplicity which is a michael
keaton film in which he gets cloned
several times rick is angry because
they'll not remember but everyone else
will and jerry breaks free and says he
shouldn't have promised to off himself
jerry packs up to leave and i love how
all of his clothes are the same
explaining why he never changes jerry
gives them permission to make out and
basically cooks himself which morty and
summer over here morty tries to act
normal but he just pours loads of salt
on his food and it's one of the
cringiest funniest scenes i think we've
ever had in the show so funny just
watching them react to the noise and
it's probably the most awkward
thanksgiving ever beth says goodbye and
rick puts away the wine and amongst this
we can also see he has a tequila like
drink with morty inside of it normally
you use a worm here but i guess morty is
a worm so he's just as good go to the
post credit scene and we see jerry going
to the jerry burrie first introduced in
morty knight run this was a place for
all jerry's to hang out and we
discovered that some have been showing
up to touch others so they aren't
allowed in without a chaperone down a
dark alleyway jerry meets another
version of himself and he ends up
kissing him might be a reach but this
could be a call back to the black mirror
episode titled striking vipers this was
about a fighting game where two players
met up and had a fight and they then got
it on and decided to meet up in the real
world the pair kissed and with all the
other fighting stuff i i kind of feel
like it's tied in again might be a reach
but i thought i'd bring it up anyway
that's the episode and so far i'm really
enjoying the series i think this was the
weakest of the three but still it's
really well put together and a great
episode about self love as well as how
awkward i've heard thanksgiving can be
this had the potential to be really
weird and cringey and though the more
you think about it the worse it is i
think they definitely presented it in
the best way possible
lots of fun overall and obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts now we are in
competition right now and giving away
three copies of thor love and thunder on
the 15th of october all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
if you pick the comments at random at
the end of the month and the winners of
the last one are on screen right now say
that to you then message me on twitter
heavy spoilers if you want some else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of the last episode which will
be linked on screen right now you've
gone over the entire thing all the
easter eggs in it and definitely head
over there right after this without the
way thanks for sticking through the
video i've been poor i'll see in the
next one take care peace